tanks will be crucial for any planned
Ukrainian spring offensive modern tanks
such as Leopard 2 and the U.S Abrahams
have high-tech armor to improve
survivability and a very powerful Cannon
which can be fired accurately on the
Move day or night and with a variety of
different ammunition
president zielinski has asked for 300
modern tanks although the M1 Abraham's
tanks is very capable this risks playing
to the Kremlin rhetoric that this war is
a battle between the East and the West
between Russia and U.S led NATO as a
result the US was almost certainly Keen
to see The Leopard 2 deployed first
despite historical and constitutional
concerns now that Germany has agreed to
send leopard twos to Ukraine numerous
other countries are likely to also throw
their weights behind zielinski's request
although at this stage the total Falls
well short of the 300 tanks requested we
might expect to see the totals rise over
the coming days
but translating a commitment into
fielded military capability takes time
and transporting these 65-ton tanks
together with their spares ammunition
and support equipment halfway around the
world will take weeks however training
the ukrainians to operate these modern
tanks could take months if Ukraine was
able to liberate experienced tank
experts this chain training could be
achieved more swiftly particularly
exploiting the West's high-tech
simulators
we might expect Ukraine to focus these
valuable assets on their primary
offensive efforts so although they could
be used in the donbass around bakmut or
further north on the p-66 Russian
resupply lines we should expect them to
be the tip of the sword of any Ukrainian
attack on the land bridge between Crimea
and the donbass
in response Russia has announced that
plans to field its own modern tank the
t-14 armata to counter this threat but
in reality the T14 has not yet been used
in battle is available in very limited
numbers and is reported to be very
unreliable
Little Wonder then that Russia has
rumped up its threatening rhetoric over
recent days as they recognize the
decisive role that Western tanks might
play in this war